how about we
all start listening to britney spears
she certainly deserves a hell of a lot
more than a low-rent mommy dearest in a
boxy suit
britney says she felt traumatized
exploited and demoralized
telling the court i just want my life
back
britt blasted her father jamie spears
and everyone involved in her
conservatorship saying quote
they should be in jail it was
interesting to watch all the lawyers
faces as she was
saying this and it looked like everyone
was trying to have a very
expressionless face but it was
definitely dramatic
to make the allegations that she made
about
you know comparing what she was going
through to sex trafficking
and abuse i mean these are some pretty
strong allegations
britney who spoke for 30 minutes by
phone got specific about her abuse
claims
one allegation she was forced to tour in
2018
even when she was sick
[Music]
sadly you know britney's story kind of
sounds like all of these people in her
life were using her as a cash cow
they were using her to make money
another claim
she had to pay 60 000 a month to go to
rehab
brit says she cried on the phone for an
hour about it to her dad who quote loved
every minute of it
adding he loved the control to hurt his
own daughter
one hundred thousand percent i think
that she's definitely
taking the offensive the truth is always
in the middle she's probably
exaggerating stuff
and so is the following jamie's legal
team responded to brittany's claim with
the statement
saying he loved brittany very much and
was quote sorry to see his daughter
suffering and in so much pain
britney also shared details from her
private medical history
she said that in 2019 when she didn't
want to do another vegas residency
she says she was forced to take the
psychiatric medication lithium which
made her feel
drunk lithium is a very hard drug
especially for very hardcore bipolar
individuals
i have a lot of clients on lithium but
they take it freely
and it has helped them tremendously and
remember these instagram posts
i am fine yes i'm totally fine i'm the
happiest i've ever been in my life
britney says her carefree instagram
persona has been a lie
quote i've been in denial i've been in
shock i'm not happy
so why did britney take so long to
reveal all of this
well the singer said she was afraid and
honestly didn't know she could petition
to have the conservatorship
ended it is almost somewhat hard to
believe but the way she said it was very
believable
but one of the most startling courtroom
revelations britney claims under the
conservatorship
she's not allowed to get married or have
a baby do you like being a mom
yes i love being a mom when i have more
kids i would love to have more kids
that was brit back with et in 2013 and
yesterday she told a judge
she was forced into using an iud for
birth control
quote this so-called team won't let me
go to the doctor to take it out because
they don't want me to have any more
children
shockingly that's perfectly legal under
conservatorship you do
have someone that makes medical
decisions on your behalf
and ultimately that person would have
the final say on whether or not this was
removed or not
in some instances patients truly can't
make medical decisions for themselves
dr nita landry of the doctor says if
brittany does get the device removed
she faces another battle britney's
approaching 40 so she would be
considered advanced fraternal age
she can have more difficulty getting
pregnant
and britt's getting support from her ex
justin timberlake
after coming under fire in the framing
britney spears documentary
jt tweeted quote what's happening to her
is just not right
no woman should ever be restricted from
making decisions about her own body
as for boyfriend of four years sam
esgari he's also been supportive and
told us
exclusively back in 2019 that he saw a
future with the pop star
is she the one do you see marriage in
the future i mean absolutely
we're a family if i wasn't under the
restraints that i'm under right now
i feel so liberated i'm sad
a source tells e.t brittany and sam
basically live their life as a couple
under curfew
she wants to be free of all the
restrictions that includes being able to
get married
earlier this year sam called britt's
conservator dad jamie an expletive in a
fiery post claiming he is quote
trying to control sam's relationship
with his daughter
the reports of your dad doing a
background check is that not true
that is true that is true yeah in 2013
the pop star admitted to e.t her dad was
definitely overprotective
at the time she was in a nearly two-year
relationship with former bartender david
lucato
does david and your father get along
yeah they get along
in just 24 hours there were more than a
million tweets about brit
mariah carey encouraged her to stay
strong while halsey admired her courage
and khloe kardashian said you deserve
better
brittany name dropped some fellow celebs
in her testimony first
paris hilton her initial reaction to
paris's
documentary about what happened to her
in boarding school was
that she didn't know if she believed it
and she was worried nobody
would believe her what's your reaction
to that
she should know we believe her free
brittany
we love brittany then there's vocal brit
supporter miley cyrus
both have the same management brit
called out the unfairness saying
she smokes on joints on stage at the
vmas nothing is ever done to this
generation for doing wrong things
but my precious body has worked for my
dad for the past 13 years
trying to be so good and pretty